la course aux armements et relancer lors
d'un meeting ce vendredi donald trump a
accusé la russie d'avoir volé une
technologie américaine du temps de
l'administration obama
selon lui si la russie possède des
missiles hypersonique aujourd'hui c'est
uniquement grâce aux compétences des
américains vous savez ils ont un missile
le super du père hypersonique je
l'appelle super du père parce qu'il va
cinq fois plus vite qu'un missile normal
d'accord nous en avons 1 qui va plus
vite que ça mais la russie a eu cette
information de l'administration obama
la russie a volé cette information vous
savez la russie paye ces informations
puis ils l'ont construit mais à présent
on en a un bon coup beaucoup plus rapide
que syndicat celui là c'est comme un
sigle à les considérer comme un missile
en en cause les missiles hypersonique
russe avant garde qui selon donald trump
serait une copie des missiles américains
l'a dit mi-août in s'est quant à lui
défendu de cette accusation
dans un entretien avec herbert tu es
from of un ingénieur qui a travaillé sur
le projet avant garde le président russe
explique pourquoi ces missiles ont été
produits des missiles imaginé et créé
bien avant que donald trump ou même
barack obama n'arrive au pouvoir
le retrait des etats-unis du traité anti
missiles balistiques en 2002 a forcé la
russie a lancé l'élaboration de barney
personnic nous avons dû créer ses armes
en réponse au déploiement par les états
unis d'un système de défense antimissile
stratégique
il y à terme auraient été capables de
neutraliser de mettre à zéro l'ensemble
de notre potentiel nucléaire
c'est ainsi qu'en décembre dernier
moscou a annoncé la mise en service de
ces premiers missiles hypersonique
avant-garde des missiles révolutionnaire
capable d'atteindre une vitesse
supérieure à trente trois mille
kilomètres heure en plus de leur vitesse
ces missiles ont la particularité de
pouvoir changer de cap et d'altitude en
plein vol ce qui les rend beaucoup plus
difficile à neutraliser avant garde
serait donc bien la conséquence d'une
décision américaine celle de se retirer
du traité anti balistiques pour l'heure
un seul traité sur la limitation des
armements est encore en vigueur entre
les deux
i et sera caduc en février prochain
selon moscou les états unis ne manifeste
pas de réelle volonté de prolonger ce
traité